[Music]
for aluminum Monday and welcome
everybody to the first episode of
skating for learning your part of
history
congratulations to join in on this
challenge remember to smash like right
now in this video if you laugh you will
jump into it it's over the phone rings
and this boy says there's this video I
swear to god the dumbest
will get me every time it's not even
funny
that's the thing I'm gonna know Glen the
second it's over the phone rings and
this boy says no okay all right
I may have laughed a little bit just a
tiny bit but it doesn't count it doesn't
work like that I have three health bars
you have zero don't make me get angry no
I got nothing all right
lamp leaves are just cranky that was
last week's meme Wow
[Music]
sheis you know over there yeah Coolio
gee I haven't even watched Jojo I know
shame on me I'm not allowed to be part
of these memes I've shared this video
five times already come on everyone we
have an announcement to make so I
thought it would be something else I
thought they would add in something else
but I guess not
I guess like we have an announcement to
make my heart hey sweet I can't it's too
innocent I can't
up up and away with Sam Pizza time
what time is it guys it's Pizza time
make sure you sign the petition let's
have Tobey Maguire in the next
spider-man oh yeah all right let's check
my health bar Wow looks like I'm doing
great
how are you doing leave a comment down
below not to feed a video more algorithm
metrics to make it positive for more
views and recommendation just because
I'm curious how you're doing immediately
the probe began recording a strange song
coming from the comet's surface
described as a drilling or clicking
noise it confused experts who to this
days all right what is it gonna be it
could be okay basically a monkey it
could be a mockney some scientists
believe that the magnetic field
surrounding the comet caused the sounds
but what is this sound
no no no no no anything but that Sam
anything but that sounds not really a
pumpkin no monkeys are terrified I know
what in the frickin world was that
basically a pumpkin no lore just cuts
out
yeah Wow now I have this vocal cords
this is the crack version of pyro
[Music]
why is ben shapiro peek meme right now
can someone explain this betcha pair up
we need ben shapiro hosting the next
meme review that's the only way let's
keep going guys wow it looks like i'm
going great that must mean this video is
garbage
this is so sad can we still hit 500
likes thank you
that's right i still put memes that are
over years old
that became unfunny and dead for long
time i don't need friends they
disappoint me why wait what's the
original here we go Karla Karla sure
Karla show everybody hi my name is Karla
saw Jesus does she do better help review
so my god that's terrifying and you can
try online therapy you can stop at five
or six stores or just one oh my god I
don't need friends they disappoint me Oh
[Applause]
better with each it slaps Fergana I
don't need friends they disappoint me I
didn't see why she put the hand come on
what's your emergency
okay stay where you are we're gonna send
someone over right now you do not have
to do
if there's a dog it could be rabid do
not approach it so is everything okay oh
yeah
okay great may I ask how does a dog into
your house
well I thought a doggie door last week
is another one oh come on here Oh Greg
Arnie this is so wholesome oh look it's
the clip again what am I gonna do you
have an announcement to make
okay my dad sent me this one dad window
strike a great ad what's the point of
being alive follow me to the window son
look look out there what do you see
moon huh
stars this is boring look closer my
child you will see the answers you seek
I see something I see a grilled cheese
it's a good point the first T of the day
PlayStation 1
[Music]
why do I feel so uncomfortable peeking
okay Yanni will be smile you guys have
bunny boots drop
elicit kinder eggs yes you're getting
their trash that's right so that's right
that's right
that was amazing
it's much like if you think traps is you
know less and the video there guys looks
like we're out of time I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did stop that
below rap leave a like it I don't know
why I keep feeling like something does
it even do anything I don't even care
what I do care about however is money
merch available limited time check out
in description thank you very much main
review and revise a YouTube favorites
[Music]
you